(lively music)
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly] Woo!
♪ What's the sense in sharing
this one and only life ♪
♪ Ending up just another
lost and lonely wife ♪
♪ You count up the years and
they will be filled with tears ♪
♪ Love only breaks up
to start over again ♪
♪ You'll get the baby but
you won't have your man ♪
♪ While he's busy loving
every woman that he can ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Say I'm gonna leave
a hundred times a day ♪
♪ It's easier said than done ♪
♪ When you just can't break away ♪
♪ Just can't break away ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Young hearts, run free ♪
♪ No, never be hung up ♪
♪ Hung up like my man and me ♪
♪ You and me, yeah ♪
♪ Oh, young hearts, to yourself be true ♪
♪ Don't be no fool when
love really don't love you ♪
♪ Oh, it don't love you ♪
Come on!
(lively music continues)
♪ Oh, young hearts, run free ♪
♪ No, never be hung up,
hung up like my man and me ♪
♪ Woo-ooh ♪
♪ My man and me ♪
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)